life
is full of twists and turns and
sometimes you just got to learn to roll
with the punches you got to learn how to
adjust
but one of the biggest lessons i learned
in 2021 is
that sometimes you got to ask for help
[Music]
hello everybody can you believe it i'm
still here and it's a new year that's
right my name is pastor corey brooks and
i'm here on this rooftop
for 100 days from november 20th to
february 28th living in this tent right
behind me on this block we call o block
the reason why we call it o block is
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs picked up his name and started
calling it o block we decided we're
going to keep the o that's right
opportunity block is what we're going to
call it
and
i can't wait
i'm so excited about this year but i've
learned some valuable lessons in 2021
i learned that one
you can never give up the life will hit
you things will come at you
life has a way of
just giving you all that it has but
whatever you do you can't throw in the
towel
you can't give up and quit
you can't jump off some bridge slit your
wrists
take amphetamines and barbiturates
hallucinogenic drugs trying to get over
your problems you cannot give up and
quit
i've learned also in 2021 that
you got to make adjustments
that that life
is full of twists and turns and
sometimes you just gotta learn to roll
with the punches you gotta learn how to
adjust
but one of the biggest lessons i learned
in 2021 is
that sometimes you gotta ask for help
in 2021 it was a year of asking for help
from me i
asked people all around the country to
help me to build this center and that
was very challenging for me i'm a very
prideful person i like to do things
independently but there's some things
that you just can't do alone
god won't let you do them alone
so my hope for this year
for 2022
is for people
to become more hopeful
i think a lot of americans
feel hopeless and
frustrated and powerless
i think a lot of us have become jaded
and selfish and
getting and protecting what what we feel
like is ours
there's a lot of mistrust in today's
world a lot of cynicism
that's why civility is decreasing and
i want to take this time to remind all
of us of that american spirit that that
america is built upon that has changed
the world
i want to remind all of us
that of that power
of togetherness of unity
that can make the world a much better
place
i want to remind you that in this year
things are going to come up
things are going to
hit you and
twists and turns are going to come
but adjust
ask for help
don't give up
and together
in 2022
with a sense of unity and purpose
we can make life better
and we muster up that spirit
that america was built upon that spirit
of unity that spirit of
passion and power and
purposefulness
we can make america what it is intended
to be
and
i'll be able to build this center
on the south side of chicago
to help a whole lot of people
god bless you and happy new year
you